how do you find your purpose I'm going
to answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan so we Scott asked a
question for one of my youtube viewers
love you guys Melvin Johnson who wrote
in the say I struggle with finding my
purpose how do I gain success without
that what direction are steps should I
take to reach the next level this is
fantastic question Melvin and finding
your purpose as one of the biggest
questions that you can ever ask yourself
and one of the most important because it
will help you lead a life that is
intentional and on purpose instead of
reactionary and just reacting to what
people are throwing at you it'll help
you live your version of your life
instead of somebody else's version of
your life so I'm going to share with you
three ways on how to help find your
purpose number one is you are wired to
help people I believe that most people
are wired to help others you feel good
when you help somebody else out right
whatever still you have whatever ability
you have when you apply it to help
somebody else out in any way even just
holding the door for a stranger and they
say thank you makes you feel good most
people and so your purpose is just a
greater extension of that it's how can I
do that on a bigger scale so what you
want to do is start looking at the
things that you do that help people that
make you feel good that make you come
alive and then try to apply that to how
can you do this two more and more and
more and more people number two is do
what you love and what helps people so
the way you're going to be able to have
that huge impact is combining something
that you really love doing something
you're passionate about something that
makes you come alive with what can help
add value to other people's lives
because if you are passionate about
something but it doesn't help other
people then it's just going to be
something for yourself and that's not
what I believe to be your purpose where
if you're helping other people but
you're not passionate about it then you
won't really help them in a big
meaningful way because you're kind of
forcing yourself to do it right yes
you're helping them but it's not
something that you love doing where the
greatest intersection will be something
that you love doing and that has a big
in
pack on helping other people and improve
in their lives and notice I didn't say
what you're good at because what you're
good at may be something that you're not
passionate about or not passion about
anymore and it's way more important to
focus on what your passion won't want to
learn because when you have that passion
excitement you could pick up any skill
right what you're good is just a skill
and when you are excited to learn
something you'll pick it up way faster
than if you're being forced to learn it
by somebody else so think about that
intersection again if what you really
love doing with what can add a lot of
value to people's lives number three is
just say yes so hopefully points 1 and 2
got you thinking of what might be your
purpose and things explore but if you
still have no idea and like I'm gonna
need more help how do i find it just
start saying yes to things start to
explore be willing to try new things out
at least once to see if it's for you or
not you know if I didn't say yes when
the YMCA asked me to come and speak to
their group of entrepreneurs I probably
wouldn't be doing what I'm doing right
now with his youtube channel and finding
my passion for entrepreneurs if I didn't
say yes to one day going to a salsa club
ourselves a class to learn the basic
steps even though you know I'm too tall
and never heard the music before then I
wouldn't have met my wife and I wouldn't
have become an investor in a salsa
dancing business right it's had a huge
impact on my life and I say yes to a lot
of things that doesn't mean that I
continue on a lot of things you know
I'll try almost anything once and then
if I don't like it I move on but by
saying yes and by trying things you'll
eventually find something that you are
passionate about and could lead to your
purpose by sitting in your house all day
and not saying yes and not opening up
yourself then you're just going to
continue to sit there and think and
think and think and get more and more
depressed so start saying yes and as
Steve Jobs likes to say in one of his
videos you'll know when you find it and
so when you fall in love with something
you want to keep doing it is having a
big impact in helping other people
you'll know that that's your purpose
you'll find it and you want to keep one
with it so remember you're wired to help
people do what you love and what helps
others
just say yes believe thank you for the
great question Melvin I hope that helped
and for those of you watching I love to
know what your purpose is or how you
found it so that can help other people
as well leave it in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon